hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode 3 video they
did all kinds of comic-book things just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet I really feel like
bringing Harrison wells and Jesse quake
back and the energy up the scene where
Harrison wells is just going back and
forth with Caitlin and Cisco that first
time when Jessie quick runs off probably
one of my favorite scenes of dialogue in
the entire episode which is great
writing across the board and the way
they weave the narratives together let's
do top 10 WTF Easter eggs there was so
much comic book stuff happening in this
episode starting with number 10 Barry
and iris finally go on a date so a lot
of people will probably go crazy about
this I feel like they balanced it well
enough that it didn't turn into like
complete melodrama fan fiction because
they're gonna get together eventually
but not before a bunch of other stuff
gets in the way like Barry's always
gonna be the flash there's always gonna
be threats so I let the way he had to
pause the date to go capture the robber
and then he finally gets that kids that
he's been watching but the really
important thing that iris said they kind
of synched up with the Wally West
storyline is the you're perfect without
your powers so just remember that
because I feel like they did a lot of
foreshadowing in this episode so number
9 Jesse quick Harrison wells come back
she has powers and based on the way they
explained it earth 2 was not affected by
flashpoint which i think is the smart
way to go like you don't to make Barry
so powerful that his derps could destroy
the universe like just destroy the
fabric of reality everywhere but the way
they explain it is that last year when
they rebooted Barry's powers which is
actually like a scene from the
flashpoint paradox movie so like they
already kind of did a little bit of
flashpoint last year but during that
they were hit by the Dark Matter blast
it infused their DNA and then Jesse
quake eventually went back to earth to
at the end of the season and nothing
happened until she almost got hit by a
car like a moment of extreme stress
life-or-death that activated her powers
so number eight WTF which is like the
funniest moment ever just totally
perfect the way the actors played it
while he just nods his head steps in
front of a car I just love the way they
played that like of course she's like
okay I just need to risk my life that'll
activate my powers number seven
Julian Albert learns about a special
element that all the metas have in
common
so they said it enough times in the
context they use it and it make me feel
like they were just laying in Easter
eggs for mr. element who was one of the
aliases of dr. alchemy there's just like
a lot of dr. alchemy that's permeating
all aspects of the first part of this
season so the other side of that number
six magenta has an alternate personality
so there's this duality that they're
talking about here with the other
timeline the other self a powerful
version of you that alchemy is trying to
make a reality so you have this Darth
Vader Anakin Skywalker style battle
going on inside magentas head and the
reason why I think they picked this
character from the comics to do is one
because she's a lot of fun but to dr.
alchemy in the comics also has a split
personality the light side of him is
called Albert Desmond the dark side of
him is named Alvin and he is dr. alchemy
so just a big theme of the episode is
split personality like she blacked out
whenever magenta took over so maybe dr.
alchemy is somebody with the split
personality in one side does not know
about the other but just something to
think about I don't think they're gonna
reveal who dr. alchemy is for at least a
little while longer but we're starting
to see more clues like they're starting
to seed things in multiple personalities
mr. element number five caitlin snow
kind of like the mouthpiece of the
episode talks about meat you know maybe
if you were to help Jesse quick and talk
her through this rather than antagonize
her she wouldn't push you away so she's
kind of using this Jesse quick moment as
a mouthpiece for her own frustrations
with her powers Jesse if I had powers I
would take it slow like she's just
slowly starting to learn about her own
killer frost powers so very apropos use
of her character in like the dialogue
the scenes that she had in the episode
number four was the Jesse quick Barry
team-up she's already really good with
her powers like she's been using them
for a little while
she's also smarter than most of the
other people in STAR Labs so she
probably has ideas about the way to use
her powers that other people haven't
thought of like she'll probably come up
with some cool new way to use flash
powers that Barry hasn't thought of yet
because the way she thinks is so
different from Barry a great action set
piece it was kind of like the Darth
Vader Return of the Jedi moment I sense
the good in you like he kind of has to
talk magenta down while Jesse quick is
keeping the oil tanker from crushing the
building but even cooler number three
Jesse quick gets her very own speedster
costume it's basically a reworked
version of trajectory's costume from
last year so that costume is actually
inspired by the comic book costume of
Johnny quick from the crime syndicate on
earth three now the TV show has done
something a little bit different with
the different earths of the multiverse
so like Jay Garrick is from earth 3 but
in the comics crime syndicate is from
earth 3 the flash of their team is
Johnny quick and he wears a costume that
has like Lightning down the sides just
like this so the way they explain in the
episode is that she's gonna be around
for a little while longer but violet
being the actress said that because
she's not a series regular like Tom
Cavanagh is they'll find creative ways
to keep Harrison wells on earth one
while Jesse quick has to go back but
number two is all the creepy Julianne
Albert stuff in the episode tom felton
is great but Julianne Albert is a creepy
character he pushed magenta over the
edge probably knowing that she would
snap so already he seems like kind of a
dick in the way he was pushing things at
the end of the episode so even though
I'm expecting a bit of a misdirect like
they changed dr. Alchemy's backstory a
little bit from the comics I think that
he is definitely involved with things
whether he knows it or not just remember
the idea split personalities just
remember that the footage they were
looking at they say is dr. alchemy but
the thing is is the glove like we
actually saw the glove it's way more
hardcore than the gloves alchemy was
wearing so this might actually be Savitt
our because we haven't seen him yet and
it sounds like they're really trying to
thread him in slowly like they're trying
to do all this dr. alchemy stuff up
front
they'll probably have some big reveal
for his character and then we've
saboteur in but that's just who I think
this character is it seems like sabotage
the person who went after the rival but
of course number one WTF this is pretty
obvious Wally is very clearly going to
start hearing dr. Alka
voice inside his head just like magenta
explained like she had visions of this
other life dreams like while he's been
having but then it got really bad she
started having them during the day and
then eventually she just heard dr.
Alchemy's voice so that will probably
happen to Wally he will tempt him with
his powers and that'll be part of
Wally's arc this season so they kind of
beat us over the head with that in the
episode almost across every storyline
you're perfect without your powers Barry
Wally you're perfect without your powers
and then it all circles back around with
Caitlin speech about not pushing people
away helping them through this situation
so what we might see is a situation
whereby Wally is pushed away from team
flash in dr. alchemy takes advantage of
that if you guys didn't read the comics
there was an arc where iris West had a
brother who was an evil speedster but
his name was Daniel West not Wally so he
kind of became the new 52 reverse-flash
before eobard thawne came back so we
might see some Daniel West stuff
happening this season but just remains
to be seen the flash always tends to be
a little more hopeful so whatever ends
up happening to Wally this season I do
think they'll be able to save him by the
end so it sounds like Wally's gonna have
a pretty cool story this season Caitlin
has a cool story
Jesse quake is gonna be doing awesome
stuff and I love the new speed lab let
me know in the comments what was your
guy's favorite thing about the episode
would you think of magenta in how long
do you think it's going to be before
Wally is tempted by dr. alchemy I don't
think it's gonna be that long I think
it'll definitely happen before the
mid-season finale but just a heads up
there's a whole bunch of DC stuff that's
still happening this week so arrow
SummerSlam is happening tomorrow night
that's Stephen Amell verse Cody Rhodes
rematch because they had SummerSlam from
last year so it's gonna be like arrows
version of SummerSlam and then on
Thursday night they're doing Justice
Society of America on legends of
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
all that stuff there is a round of the
DC giveaway that's going on right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so there was some really crazy
Ghost Rider stuff that happened on
agents of shield so that in
Deadpool will be my next video there's
actually like a cool Deadpool video that
I don't want to wait too long to post
that should all be out before I post my
arrow video so hopefully I'll be able to
stay on schedule and just because I'm
doing my outros a little bit differently
because of the way that YouTube changed
up you can click up here on this top
link for the International Wonder Woman
trailer I just posted and you click on
the bottom link for the arrow trailer
for tomorrow's episode so thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five from behind the screen because you
can't see my face I'll see you guys
tomorrow